- [Interviewer] Alright.
So Lima, Lima Jevremovic,
- Jevremovic.
- [Interviewer] You have a company
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] called Aura.
And what do you guys do?
- [Lima] So we're all
about data-driven healing.
Our goal is to use technology
to scale affordable high
quality treatment services.
- [Interviewer] How'd
you start doing this?
What got you into this in the first place?
- So my, our father
growing up was very abusive
to my sisters and I,
and my mom left when I
was about five years old
and my sisters were
around three years old,
and I remembered everything,
absolutely everything.
So growing up, there
was nothing that my mom
could do to make me feel better.
I was a miserable child and
very angry all the time.
And dealing with all of
that throughout my life
and learning how to cope is what initially
made me want to go into mental health.
- [Interviewer] So, what do you
think causes these problems?
Why do you think this
exists in our society?
- Yeah, so it's not about a housing issue.
It initially started
with abolishing slavery
and trying to get cheap labor.
And that's when we began to
try to fill our prison systems,
and we closed mental
health facilities to open
up more prisons.
A lot of the funding
cuts ended up, you know,
being taken out of mental health.
And so that's why you see so many people
on the streets with mental health issues.
Another problem is that
when you look at the numbers
of people who are imprisoned,
roughly about 60% of them have,
are in there for substance
use related charges,
and roughly about the same amount, 60%,
also have diagnosed
mental health conditions
with about 20% having severe
illnesses like schizophrenia.
So it's all about,
right now, our system is about
punishment over treatment,
and really monetizing that labor.
And they're taking all of the funding away
from mental health services
and putting it into other resources,
which is completely damaging our society.
And so if we put more services,
more funding behind
mental health services,
we wouldn't have such a
horrific mental health
and homeless situation
happening in our country.
- [Interviewer] So what
you're suggesting is the
appropriate response is more treatment
for the mental health issues?
- Absolutely. It's all about
treatment over punishment
and really learning how to help people.
- [Interviewer] What
got you into this field?
I mean, your, your, your
history with your family,
it sounds like.
- Yeah. So, like I said, I
initially didn't remember,
my sisters didn't remember
any of the trauma,
but I had a, you know,
I remembered everything.
And throughout my childhood and
throughout my teenage years,
I just got mixed up with the wrong crowd.
And my sisters the poster
children for the perfect child.
They were identical twins.
They were athletes.
They had straight A's.
They had no recollection of the trauma.
And then roughly within
their mid twenties,
they began to hear voices.
And they didn't know what was going on,
but because of the mental health stigma,
they didn't come to my mom or my myself.
They kept it a secret,
but they did do the right thing,
and they sought professional help.
And so the doctors, of course,
had absolutely no tools to treat them,
their mental health therapists.
So they go and they ask
them, how are you feeling?
And then they started prescribing them
cocktails of medications and drugs.
And so at that time,
my sisters had a very
successful YouTube channel.
Their career was on the
up and up and rising.
And once they started to seek treatment
is when it all went downhill from there.
So they began, at the beginning,
they were prescribed antipsychotics,
misdiagnosed for about three years.
They were told that
they were schizophrenic,
which is not the case.
And it's the, the way that
we treat mental health
services right now is the equivalent
of me telling you, Mark, my leg hurts.
I think it's broken.
And then you ask me, well,
on a scale of one to
10, how bad is the pain?
And I look at you, and I
tell you, maybe it's a seven.
And so then you tell me, Oh,
it's probably not broken.
It's probably fractured.
Take this medication.
And if it gets worse,
then come back, and
we'll put a cast on it.
That's basically what we do to your brain.
We're playing Russian
roulette with your brain.
Every time we prescribed you medications,
we're slightly changing
the chemicals in the brain,
when we really don't
know what the issue is.
And so after three and a half years,
my sisters were finally properly diagnosed
with dissociative identity disorder,
which is extremely dangerous
to treat with antipsychotics.
Because in that three-year period
the anti-psychotics were not working,
the doctors were giving them cocktails
of antipsychotics, benzos,
so Klonopin and Xanax,
and eventually,
because the Klonopin destroys
the reward receptors,
somebody prescribed them Suboxone,
which is synthetic opioid,
and they ended up developing
a full blown opioid and benzo addiction
that's completely destroyed our family.
So, but initially,
the cycle is that they go
to treatment for 30 days
because that's what insurance will cover.
The first approximately
10 days is horrible
'cause you're just detoxing your body.
After that,
when the drugs are completely
out of your system,
and they're trying to
treat you with therapy,
for about two weeks, your brain,
essentially medications are like
putting your brain in a wheelchair.
So if I put you in a
wheelchair for three years,
and then I ask you to stand up, you're,
you're not going to be able to walk,
nonetheless be able to even
stand on, on your legs.
And so if you've been taking
meds or self-medicating
or very dependent on
different types of medications
and then they're taken away
from you and you've detoxed,
your brain doesn't know
how to manually produce
the chemicals on its own.
It's very dependent
and has been essentially
crippled by this medication.
So during that detox period,
as soon as your body's
completely kept cleansed
of those chemicals,
it doesn't know how to
produce it on its own,
and it's very much depleted,
so you just feel awful all the time.
And a lot of times,
those people need to sit
in that awful feeling,
and it's too overwhelming
for them to do so.
And so initially after detox,
the following about two weeks
is the brain learning how to function
without that medication.
So you are just hating life.
Therapy's not getting through to you.
Nothing's really making sense.
You just want to leave.
And then your brain is now
starting to produce its own
chemicals and function on its own.
It's, you're learning how to
stand up, let's say, right,
all over again.
That physical therapy's
starting to have an effect.
So the last week of treatment,
the last week of that 30 days,
you're starting to benefit,
and you're starting to seem
like you're getting better.
And then you're immediately released
because insurance won't
cover continued care.
The reason for that is
because it costs about $45,000 per month
for somebody to get treatment in resident,
in a residential facility.
That doesn't include the
initial hospitalization,
the detox period, and
all of the medications
and everything else that goes into that.
And it's, it's very expensive,
but the relapse rate is 90%.
So with a 10% success rate,
the insurance companies
are saying, we are not,
we're not going to fund 45, 45, 45,
when you have such a high relapse rate.
The clinics, it's a catch 22,
because the clinics are
initially saying, well,
on average, most patients
have been self-medicating
or initially addicted
or harming themselves
for 15 years or more.
They've been, they've been taking this,
these matters into their own hands.
And you can't expect us to change 15 years
of a behavior pattern in only 30 days
and then expect it to last.
And so with my sisters' case,
they've been to over 60 treatment centers,
and the story's always the same.
It's 30 days of treatment.
You know, they leave, there's
no door to door treat,
there's no door to door care.
There's such a high
demand for these services,
that there's not enough doctors to treat
the number of patients
that needs, needs help.
Especially since the opioid epidemic,
there's been a 600% increase
in the number of patients
trying to admit themselves
into treatment.
So there's a nationwide
shortage of beds and doctors
and staff and support and help.
And so they leave the 30 day treatment.
They feel suddenly like
they're on their own.
A lot of these people, as you know,
have this story that they tell themselves
that nobody cares about me.
I'm by myself.
Nobody, nobody wants to help me.
So when they're starting
to get better in a facility
and then they find
themselves abandoned again,
then they just feel like
I'm completely alone
with my illness or my addiction,
And the only thing that they know,
because the thing that makes
them feel better is an instant
immediate satisfaction,
whether that be cutting, whether
it be high risk behaviors,
being promiscuous,
compulsive caffeine consumption,
shopping addiction like me, right?
So there's, there's so
many different ways.
And these are very common.
These are what I call
negative coping skills.
So they're very common,
but addiction is not just an
addiction to drugs or alcohol.
It's initially the
inability to say no. Right?
So it's, it's the,
it's the inability to set
those boundaries for yourself.
And I noticed that a lot of times you ask,
I mean, I think every time,
you ask the people that
you're interviewing,
tell me about your childhood.
- [Interviewer] Every time.
- It really does start in childhood
because you need a healthy balance.
So if, if someone comes from a place
where there's too many boundaries, right,
where the parents are very,
very strict with them,
and they're, you know,
can be also abusive in
in how strict they are,
that can be completely debilitating
to a child growing into an adult.
And the same thing can be with no fre-,
with too much freedom,
where parents just allow
you to do whatever you want.
Children need healthy boundaries
so that they can learn to say no,
and they can, they can
understand their self-worth.
And you have to find that balance.
But if you have parents
that are too freeing
and are, are too consumed with what
they're personally involved in
and they don't pay attention to the kids,
or if you have kids that are,
parents that are too controlling,
you have your boundaries
completely screwed up.
And so that's, that's where it all starts,
with not having proper boundaries in place
and, and becoming addicted
to your own self-destruction.
And a lot of times when we say treatment,
people assume that going to therapy is,
so Mark, tell me about how you're feeling,
and then you just puke
everything out on me.
And then you leave,
and you feel great after
your therapy session.
That's really not how therapy works.
Therapy starts when you step
outside the door. Right?
So one of therapists, her name is Alana,
and she, she uses our technology.
She works with veterans.
So she always tells her,
her veterans that therapy is all theory.
And it starts, the work
starts when you leave.
The reason that she loves our technology
is because she's able to track
how the patients are doing.
We use voice analysis.
We use biofeedback.
So you can actually see
how a patient's feeling.
I'm not just asking you,
how bad is the pain? Right?
I'm actually, I give the
doctors the tools to see,
so if you tell me that,
you know, you're fine.
And I look, and I can
see that you're not fine.
Addicts are master manipulators.
They have it spot on, on how to trick you.
And on top of that, my sisters
are the best actresses.
So it's hard enough for me to read them,
but being able to have
tools that, you know,
when, when someone's been just so,
gone to treatment, it hasn't helped.
Gone to treatment, it hasn't helped.
They initially give up on treatment,
and they feel like they know better.
And especially when I
go in to see a doctor,
and they ask me, how are you feeling?
And I tell them, I'm fine.
And they're like, Oh, that's good.
Then I feel like I can't trust that doctor
because they can't see behind the mask,
so they can't help me.
So if it's so easy for me to fool you,
then you can't help me.
And so that, that
initially discredits a lot
of the therapists or the therapy sessions,
the ability to just be able to see
how the patient's feeling.
We also use virtual reality,
so we can put patients in
triggering environments.
And, you know, for example,
we put a patient in a bar,
or we put, or for our veterans,
we put them in a war zone.
We've learned a lot about their
response to certain things.
It just gives us a lot.
It's all about having
that vast richness of data
to really be able to analyze the situation
and steer the conversation in a path
that it wouldn't have gone otherwise,
just because there's so many
walls around these people
that they're just not
willing to let someone in.
So you kind of have to find
a way to gain their trust
and show them that you
actually can help them
and that you can see how they feel,
and it's not all in their head.
Because especially with my sisters,
there's been so many
times where they've said,
maybe DID isn't real.
Maybe nobody can help me.
I'm just crazy.
Because up until now, no one
has been able to help them.
- [Interviewer] So, so
your company really gives
the therapist a window into
what's really going on?
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] With the patient.
So initially, it's kind of like-
- [Interviewer] Not just their words.
- Absolutely.
So, so think of it as like
therapy and medication, right?
You do need both,
and, but you, but you need
medication in moderation, right?
Not the way that we
currently prescribe it,
where it leads to, you know, addiction,
but, and dependency.
You need, and you also need therapy.
So right now our system
relies purely on medication
and very little on, on therapy.
Therapy is just there so we say we do it,
but it's medication to sedate
everybody and manage them.
And the way that I, the
way that I initially
describe to patients or colleagues
is it's like a fire alarm, right?
So when I have a really awful feeling,
that means that, and it could
even be a midlife crisis,
whatever it is, doesn't even
have to be an addiction, right?
When I have a bad feeling,
that bad feeling's actually really good.
It's telling me that something's wrong,
and you need to learn to
sit in it and analyze it,
initially track and unpack that feeling.
So if there's a fire going
off and you take medication,
it's initially like me getting up,
taking the batteries out of the fire alarm
and then going back to sleep.
So I'm going back to sleep
in a burning building.
And you know, the side
effects are suicide,
self-harm, just, you know,
they're all horrific. Right?
Because if you depend on that long enough,
the building's gonna burn down,
and you have no warning signs.
Therapy is about looking for
where the fire is. Right?
And so that's, that's what our goal is
is to scale treatment
so that you can learn
how to sit in these bad feelings
and that you're, you're,
when you refer to that feeling,
it's not, I feel awful.
'Cause I hear that from
my sisters all the time.
I feel awful.
It's about being aware of your feelings.
So, is it sad?
Is it fear?
Is it anger?
What is that feeling?
And then let's analyze
where it's coming from.
And once you can identify
what triggered that feeling,
you can identify how to
initially respond to it,
or you can identify, you know,
how to avoid certain things that end up
leading to that feeling.
And it's like a domino effect.
But if you're constantly,
like, I feel awful.
This is a bad feeling.
Let me take the batteries
out of the fire alarm.
Then you're constantly
quieting that feeling,
and you're not getting better.
- [Interviewer] So for your,
if a pa-, if the therapist
is speaking with a patient
and there may be some shame or anxiety or,
or something going on that
they're masking or hiding,
that therapist kind of
has a window into it?
- Absolutely. So they can, they can see,
we use evidence-based scales.
So depending on what the patient is
diagnosed with,
right now, our biggest
focus is on depression.
We are a very young company.
It's a startup, and I started on my own.
- [Interviewer] How many
years has Aura been around?
- It's been a year.
It's been around for a year,
but I've been doing the research
for, for about seven years.
So we were, it was registered last April.
We, we managed to raise
a small seed round.
We have 19 clinics that are
currently signed up with us.
We have about 600 clinics
that want to sign up with us,
but we just don't have a big
enough team to support them.
And we, we don't have the tools to scale,
scale or technology right now.
So what we're working on is
we're getting ready to open
up our series A with private
investors next month.
We've had some really good traction
and a lot of really great conversations.
And there's it, it's amazing to see
how many of these investors have
experienced mental illness in loved ones,
and they're very motivated
with the same reasons
that I'm motivated by.
So I couldn't imagine
being in a better industry
because there's so much heart in it.
It's not all about how
much money we can make.
Of course there are those people,
but those are not the
people we want to work with.
It's about the people that
are thinking of how can we
scale help for so many,
for, for everybody.
And if you look at the
different tiers of treatment,
so some of the patients that,
or some of the people
that you've interviewed,
were talking about
different treatment centers
that they went to, and they, they were,
didn't have insurance, they
had Medicaid or Medi-Cal,
and you know, those
treatment facilities, they,
they typically have very
small rooms, twin beds.
It kind of looks like a
nice jail cell. Right?
They're, and they're clients of mine.
So we, we work with them. Right?
So it's not talking bad about them.
It's just giving you an image
of the different tiers of treatment.
They don't, they have
a small outdoor space.
It's very closed off.
There's not really a lot of nature,
and it's just a very
clinical, hospital vibe.
And then we have,
so those ones go for
about like 18,000 a month
to 35,000 a month.
Then we have luxury facilities that go
from 45,000 upwards to 135,000 a month.
There are cash pay private facilities and
beautiful houses on the water
or just in a beautiful neighborhood,
surrounded by, you know,
completely surrounded by nature,
and you don't feel like
you're in a hospital setting.
And those, the Medicare
Medi-Cal facilities
will usually have
about like a hundred, 200
patients, not a large staff.
It's mostly group therapy.
It's initially a place to
hold your family member
for 30 days until they relapse.
So it's, it's a bit, it's
the glorified babysitter
that's holding them. Right?
The private pay facilities, they're,
they have a smaller,
they take less people,
which is why they charge
a higher price point.
And they also do more one-on-one therapy.
And, and they have,
you know, it's enjoyable to be there.
You actually feel like
people care about you.
And it's beautiful.
I would check myself into
one of these facilities
just for the sake of a vacation,
like it's, it's just
very serene and tranquil.
And so with our technology,
with our virtual reality,
what we're doing is we're
taking the highest quality
of care, so the beaches
and the beauty of nature
and the mindfulness practices that they do
at these higher tier treatment centers,
and we're providing a virtual
room where these patients can,
in these other facilities,
can go and can be on a beach
and can be in the mountain tops
and can do mindfulness
and positive practices
because around like four o'clock,
the therapist will go home,
and the patients are just
left with the TV room,
and they're just being
held there and medicated.
And so that's not very practical.
So with our tools,
we're constantly trying to
replace negative coping skills
with positive coping skills.
So if you're someone
that's very impulsive,
that's use to, you know, cutting
yourself when you're upset
or throwing up or overeating
or taking your drug of choice,
right?
Those are all negative
coping skills, and you,
and you've gotten used to doing them
because the first time
that you ever do anything
it's very nerve-wracking.
And then the second time you do it,
it's a little familiar,
but it's still, you know,
it's still makes you a little nervous.
And then the third time,
fourth time, fifth time,
eventually it becomes
abnormal to not do it.
So for example,
if you're someone that goes
to the gym six days a week,
and you miss a day of your workout,
you're going to feel awful
about yourself. Right?
'Cause you are you're, you
have that, that daily routine,
and you just broke it.
But if you're somebody that,
and I've been there, right.
So I'll have like that daily routine,
and I'll be like, Oh, I can't
believe I screwed it up.
And then, you know, since my sister drama,
I haven't been working
out like I was before.
And all of a sudden,
if I go to the gym once a
week, I'm so proud of myself.
But the following day that I don't go,
it's not a big deal to me
because I'm used to not going.
So that becomes my
behavior pattern, whatever,
whatever I'm used to is,
is what I constantly follow and
what I reward, or, you know,
put myself down for.
When it comes to self-harm,
like if someone, for example,
with an eating disorder, if
they're used to, if they,
at the beginning, they
throw up for the first time.
It's kind of scary.
You know, it's a scary thing
to eat, to even comprehend.
It's very uncomfortable.
I don't think anyone likes
the feeling of puking. Right?
So it's not a comfortable feeling.
It's not a comfortable act
and it's a little, it's a little scary.
And so when they begin to
do that on a daily basis,
it begin, it becomes very
uncomfortable for them
not to throw up
because now they've retained that food,
and it's about control,
and you didn't control
your in, your food intake,
and you didn't throw up.
And so that becomes the norm,
so you reprimand yourself
for not doing it.
So you broke that schedule
or that comfort level
that you have created.
And that became your way of
coping with stress and trauma.
When I feel a certain
way, I respond this way.
And when I don't do it,
whether that be pills,
whether that be, you know,
food consumption and just
comfort eating, right,
whatever it is that you do,
therapy is about breaking that pattern.
But if you don't get the therapy,
if you don't get constant therapy,
constant practice at
breaking in that pattern,
then initially, you're never gonna,
you're gonna ever get a break it,
and you're always going to go
back to what you're used to.
And so that's why the relapse rate is 90%,
and people are not getting better.
And unfortunately, this isn't, you know,
eating disorders have the
highest rate of mortality
because, especially when
you pair it with bulimia,
like anorexia has the
highest rate of mortality,
and when you pair that with bulimia, your,
your heart has a higher
rate of just stopping.
Like it just stops out
of, you know, it can't,
it can't continue to support the body.
Opioids.
Opioids now kill more,
more Americans than guns
or breast cancer.
And it's just because people
have become so dependent
on impulsively changing
how they're feeling,
and they're very addictive.
The goal of what we do and
what therapy is supposed to do,
but they don't have the tools to do it,
and that's why we're
building the tools to do it,
is initially to take those
negative coping skills,
get you to pause and not be
so impulsive and replace.
We're not just telling you,
stop doing drugs, stop
throwing up, stop, you know,
you're compulsive shopping
habits, Mark. Right?
We're not trying to do that.
We're trying to, we're
not trying to replace them
because you can't just stop
and not know what to do with yourself.
You have to replace them
with mindfulness practices,
not being impulsive, taking a deep breath.
One of the games that we have
is learning how to deal with
anxiety and stress and mood.
So for example,
we've gamified the fight
or flight response. Right?
So when I'm stressed
out, I'm like very tense
and in, my shoulders are up,
and I'm holding my breath.
And so I can now see it in colors.
And when I'm calm,
I'm taking a deep breath
and the colors change and,
and it's, and I have certain tasks.
So for certain tasks, I have
to be super stressed out for.
And for other tasks, I
have to be super calm.
So I learn how to control
the fight or flight response.
And stress is actually
a really good thing.
And that's what a lot of
people don't talk about it.
So if people are interested,
I would highly recommend the
book, Think Fast and Slow.
It talks about the two brain systems,
where one is very impulsive
and that can be very good,
but also one is very focused,
and it, I can break it down.
I don't know if it would be too long,
but, but yeah, it's a very good book,
and it, it really breaks
down how you need stress.
You need stress to focus.
You need stress to be motivated.
If you know those people, I'm one of them,
that will usually have like
two weeks to do an essay,
and then the night before the essay's due,
you end up cramming, and you
just write the whole thing,
and you pull an all nighter
and then you submit it. Right?
That's because those people,
like when you have ADD
or when you're just very
when you're always thinking fast, right,
you can't sit there and focus.
But all of a sudden when stress kicks in,
my essay's due tomorrow.
I can't fail this class.
That stress actually gets you
to sit down and hyper-focus
and finish it in one night.
So stress can be very,
very, very productive,
but it's about learning
how to channel it. Right?
- [Interviewer] Has
Aura had success stories
with some patients?
- Yeah. So we're actually
piloting it right now.
We're working on getting
the data out there.
Due to the COVID pandemic,
we've kind of put our research on hold.
So we're still using it.
We're still tracking patients,
but we're not releasing that information
because a lot of the,
we don't want our numbers to be skewed.
A lot of the treatment centers,
they're mental health facilities.
They can support a physical outbreak
like a co, the COVID
pandemic inside the facility
'cause they don't have the staff to care
for the patients' physical illness.
So they've changed around their protocols.
We've been helping them see,
get, receive PPE supplies.
And, and so just due
to all of those shifts,
we've paused our, our data collection.
But we have, we have seen in little,
just small instances in therapy sessions,
where patients weren't even
aware of, of their feelings,
because for example,
somebody who's at a constant, like,
for let's use a scale one
to 10 for easy math, right?
So if someone's constantly
at a stress level of an eight, right,
and you ask them how they're feeling,
they're gonna think that they're fine
because they're used to
feeling this way all the time.
So right now, I'm okay. Right?
But the doctor can actually
see that they're not fine,
and that they're actually at a,
at an elevated stress level
that's being maintained
just because they're constantly on edge.
And so we've had small
little success stories
in the sense that we've been
able to identify these factors.
And we've also been able to
monitor people's craving levels
and monitor people's stress and anxiety
or even the ability to
remove triggers. Right?
When, for example, if you're
in a treatment facility,
and I put you, I put your drug
of choice in front of you,
that would be extremely unethical.
It's not allowed. Right?
There's no drugs on the premises.
If I can put that drug of
choice in front of you,
just the visual of it,
it's not the same as
me showing you a photo,
but being able to put you in a room,
through our virtual reality technology,
being able to put you in a
room where you, you know,
you essentially are by yourself. Right?
So now I'm able to test you
because it's the power of VR
and it's also, you know,
the power of being silent.
And so all of a sudden,
you're at a bar by yourself.
For example, one of our veterans, right,
he said, his rock bottom is
being at home by himself,
no one there, just sitting on the couch
with a bottle of Jack
Daniels on the table. Right?
And so, so we were able to
put him in a living room
environment by himself,
bottle on the table, and
measure his ability to
number one, use his coping skills
'cause we can see his craving levels.
We can see his, his stress
levels immediately elevate
because he's by himself.
Now, we're totally silent.
No one's saying anything.
And your, your brain just
automatically goes into a mode
where you're, you just feel like,
you know that you're
not in this environment.
You know that your
doctor is there with you
and that this is a safe place,
but it doesn't feel like it anymore
because you don't see anyone there.
And so you're in this alternate reality,
we can measure the the
trigger, the response,
the craving levels, the stress.
We stay silent and we see
how long it takes the patient
to use their coping skills,
their grounding skills,
all of the therapies that
they've been learning. Right?
'Cause these are initially exercises,
but if you don't practice them,
if I just do a couple of pushups,
we're not going to expect
to be really strong. Right?
I have to do it on a daily basis,
and I have to practice when
my trainer's not there.
So by being able to put the
patient in that environment,
stay silent and have them do
the therapies on their own,
we can now, you know, monitor the patient.
And when he's still, when he's,
let's say he's in level eight,
and he's, he gets himself down
with his grounding exercises
to a level six.
So now he's taking himself through
without the help of the doctor.
He's practicing.
It's no longer a theory, right?
It's no longer, it
starts outside the room.
Now it literally starts in
the office with the doctor.
And so when the doctor realizes
he's having trouble getting
from a six lower,
but he's gotten himself
from an eight to a six,
then the doctor will say, okay,
remember what we talked about.
Take a deep breath.
Remember the story you told
me about your grandmother
in the park.
Think of something positive.
And so the doctor's
able to get him down to
a level four. Right?
With her help talking him through it.
The ability to be able to
show that data to insurance,
we're gathering all of that information
because our goal is for
insurance to cover, you know,
six months of treatment for patients.
But the only way-
- [Interviewer] The cost
of mental health is-
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] A big problem right?
- So the cost of, of real treatment
would be about, and
this is very low, right,
would be about 250,000
for a year for somebody
if you were to constantly go door to door.
- [Interviewer] So, so you
have a scholarship program?
- Yeah. So I'm actually starting
the scholarship program.
I just registered a nonprofit called
the Jevremovic Institute of
Behavior and Brain Sciences.
And so the reason for that
is initially because I
work in mental health,
my sisters have insurance and
our family is very supportive
in working towards making sure
that they're always covered.
The treatment centers that are my clients
are beyond supportive of what
I'm doing and my situation,
are willing to discount the
beds for, for my sisters to go.
And I know, I know the
industry inside and out
when it comes to insurance and facilities
and all of the politics behind it,
and I'm still struggling
to find treatment.
So to me, it's even unfathomable
to think of people that
are uninsured or don't,
don't have any contacts
in the mental health industry.
Where would you even begin? Right?
And so the, the reason for
the mental health scholarship,
the JIBBS scholarship is
initially it costs about
20, 250,000 conservatively
'cause we do get a lot
of discounted beds through my clients.
And so it's about offering
the ability for somebody.
So every 250,000 cover
somebody for one year.
It's about offering them
the ability to not just go
to a Medicaid Medi-Cal facility,
but they're able to
attend an Aura facility,
so treatment centers
that use our technology,
receive three months of residential care,
receive the detox before that,
and then after the three
months of residential care,
they're put into an outpatient program
where they have, you know,
from 9:00 AM to 5:00 PM,
they're, they're going to
therapy and doing treatment.
And then they go home.
So they have a little bit more freedom,
but the home is a sober living.
And it's, there's a lot of
sketchy sober livings out there,
but the ones that we work with
also have the Aura technology.
And so you can continue to
practice what you were learning
in the treatment center.
So those gamified therapies that are fun
but also retrain your brain.
And they also have supervision
at these sober livings,
activities, they drive you
to and from the facilities
for your therapy sessions.
And then initially after,
after another six months,
so by month nine,
you would begin job training,
and we would cut down
your therapy sessions
to the Aura mobile app.
So you do a couple hours
a week of tele-health,
and we continue to track your progress.
So voice analysis, biofeedback
and the evidence-based practices
through the Aura Guardian
system, which is our mobile app.
And so train you for, for job placement
and ensure that you have the ability to
move out of the sober living safely
and continue on that path.
But after a year,
we've completely reprogrammed
your behavior patterns,
so you're used to doing
things differently.
You have that support
and you're not automatically cut off
from 24 seven doctors surrounding you.
You're you're given that
independence slowly,
and it's not a, I'm not ready to leave.
So, so that's what, what really drives me
is treating mental illness
like physical illness
and ensuring that everybody has access
to the type of treatment that they need.
That it's not about, you know,
I'm sorry, you can't afford to get better,
so you belong on Skid Row.
It's the, one last thing
'cause I don't want this to get too long,
but in a three-year period,
Nevada saw $80 million
in mental health cuts,
and there was 1500 cases
in that three-year period
of one hospital in Nevada
dumping patients onto the street.
It's called patient dumping.
It's very common practice.
A lot of the people from
Skid Row end up here
because the ambulance drops them off,
when they can't pay for
mental health treatment
they're not, they don't have coverage,
and they can't afford to get better.
So it's a huge issue in our country
and there's too much
potential on the street
to let it just waste away.
- [Interviewer] And then
additionally, we'll do a go,
you, you want to do a Go Fund Me campaign
for the scholarship, right?
- That would be incredible.
- [Interviewer] And then
we'll choose somebody
to be decided later.
- Yeah, so.
- [Interviewer] That we,
that you, that you think
would be a good candidate for this.
- Absolutely. So I think
it would be a really
amazing opportunity to,
right now I'm raising the funds
from my friends and family,
but anyone else that wants to participate
and really add value to someone
that they've been seeing,
so it's not a housing problem.
It's not about getting these people
an apartment or getting them a home.
Trust me, we've done it with my sisters,
and it's only escalated the situation.
And it's really about getting proper
mental health care treatment
and making sure that we take care
of this person for a year
until they're independent.
- [Interviewer] And that'll
be somebody that I've
interviewed on my channel?
- Exactly. Exactly.
And we can do updates with that person.
We can talk about the type
of treatment that they've been getting,
and, you know, use it as
a way for other people
to see the ideal of how
our healthcare system
can actually work.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And
they'll use Aura's technology
to do that.
- Absolutely. There'll only be sent
to a private pay facility
that uses Aura technology.
So the highest standard of care
with data-driven healing and
the tools for the therapist
to see how the patient is feeling
and to accurately use health
detected, detection technology
so that they don't go misdiagnosed
and to really work
one-on-one with that person
until they're capable
of being independent.
And so, you know, one of the
things that I was just sharing
with you, Mark, is the fact
that we really have to remember
that these people, it's
all about toxic shame.
So when you and I do something,
it's something that we did.
When these people do something,
it's something that they are.
And so, so they become very shame-based
and the things that they
continuously fail at
become more validation
as to how awful they are
and how they don't deserve anything.
So it's really about showing
compassion to someone,
not sending them to a treatment center
where they're being sedated for 30 days
and then released onto the streets.
It's about really providing
a system of treatment
and an actual recovery
plan for them to heal.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
So I'll, I'll leave a link
in the description of this
video, and we'll go from there.
- [Lima] Thank you so much.
- [Interviewer] Lima, thank you so much
for telling us about Aura
and your scholarship.
- [Lima] Thank you
for having me.
- [Interviewer] Very exciting.
- [Lima] Thank you. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting.
- [Lima] Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] And I wish
you the best of luck with it.
- Yeah. And so-
- [Interviewer] It sounds incredible.
- Well, I'd love to
work with you to fill in
the first scholarship person
from, from one of the people
that you've interviewed.
- [Interviewer] That
could be very exciting.
- That would be awesome.
We could do an update for your guests.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, of course.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Alright.
- [Interviewer] Alright, cool.
- Thank you for having me, Mark.
- [Interviewer] Alright,
Lima, thank you very much.
- Absolutely.
Sounds good.